Im Jahr 1968 war ich im Grenzschutz bei der Grenzschutz Kompanie Bad Leonfelden,
2. 422 als Kommandant Erster Zug eingeteilt.
Ich habe die Entwicklungen in der Tschechoslowakei mit einigem Interesse verfolgt,
vor allem da dieses Manöver schon einmal war mit diesen diversen Bewegungen.
Ich war dann trotzdem sehr überrascht als ich in den Morgennachrichten am 21. August
über die Invasion in der Tschechoslowakei berichtet wurde.
Es war ein Schock, ich habe sofort meine Familie informiert,
dass mit meiner Mobilisierung gerechnet werden müsste
und bin dann sofort ins Büro, weil ja bei einer Mobilisierung meine beruflichen Agenten,
ich war damals Kreditreferent, zu übergeben gewesen wären
und habe sofort meinen Kompaniekommandanten angerufen.
Mein Kompaniekommandant im Zivilberuf, Leiter der Agrarabteilung der Oberösterreichischen Landesregierung,
hat mir erklärt er wisse noch nichts über unsere Verwendung.
Er hätte vom Kommando Hörsching noch keine Informationen bekommen.
Ich habe dann nach einer weiteren Stunde direkt beim Kommando Grenztruppen in Hörsching angerufen
und habe die selbe Information bekommen, es sei nicht geplant den Grenzschutz aufzubieten,
das heißt für mich ist dann der Dienst völlig normal weitergelaufen.
Ein Freund von mir, nachmaliger Oberster Miliz Kollmer, ist im Zivilen nach Bad Leonfelden gefahren,
er war damals als rPAK Gruppenkommandant meinem Zug unterstellt und hat am Sammelort,
Gendarmerie Postenkommando, bereits einige Grenzjäger in Uniform vorgefunden.
Im Gendarmerie Postenkommando waren unsere Waffen und Geräte eingelagert.
Für die war die Enttäuschung natürlich groß.
Völliges Unverständnis, dass der Grenzschutz genau in dieser Situation,
für die er eigentlich auch mit aufgestellt worden ist, nicht gebraucht wurde.
Das hat dann aber auch dazu geführt, dass der Grenzschutz sehr an Sympathie verloren hat
und zwar schlicht und einfach deswegen, weil man über die Jahre her versucht hat
über Kranzniederlegungen zu Allerheiligen, über Grenzjäger Bälle und sonstige Veranstaltungen
die Kontakte zur Zivilbevölkerung zu festigen und einfach ein positives Klima zu schaffen,
welches für eine territoriale Einheit eine ganz wichtige Voraussetzung ist.